et on a suivi sept heures entrée
particulière à bordeaux dans cette ville
la mairie prévoit d'accueillir tous les
niveaux à partir du 25 mai pour
l'instant seuls quelques niveaux sont
concernés par la rentrée le rythme
scolaire est adapté forcément cours
lundi et mardi pour la moitié des élèves
aient lieu jeudi et vendredi pour les
autres le mercredi étant réservé à la
désinfection de l'établissement notre
journaliste stéphane liégeois est allé à
l'encontre des parents d'élèves de
l'école primaire stehlin écoutez j'ai
fait le choix par obligation surtout
pour travailler pour la reprise du
travail
impatiente et un peu angoissé aussi il
ya un peu des deux c'est tout nouveau et
c'est des règles qu'il faut qu'ils
enregistrent et c'est pas forcément
évident à cet âge là on a le choix
mais en fait je crois que c'est
important dans les enfants à l'école
reprend une vie normale et des rssi
stabiliser aussi je pense que c'est
important psychologiquement c'est bien
pour eux aussi pensent qu'on est partagé
entre l'envié qui retrouve l'école avec
la maîtresse et les copains ça donne une
certaine normalité
et puis là la peur et la crainte parce
qu'on parce qu'on sait pas voilà c'est
des gros points d'interrogation sur ce
qui va se passer
franchement j'ai confiance je pense que
l'école a fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour mettre en place pour toute la
sécurité autour de nos enfants oui des
nouvelles règles après je pense qu'il va
falloir compte malheureusement on
apprenne à vivre avec parce que là c'est
le couvrir d'un virus
peut-être une deuxième vague ou pas j'en
sais rien et peut-être que demain ce
sera encore autre chose